[MUSIC PLAYING]
SPEAKER 1: Hello, everyone.
My name is Juan [INAUDIBLE],,
and I am a product manager
in the continuous integration,
continuous delivery
team in Google Cloud.
Today I am going to
tell you about Artifact
Registry, the evolution of
Google Container Registry.
As the evolution of
Google Container Registry,
Artifact Registry
includes new features
like regional repositories,
multiple repositories
per project, and repository
native identity access
management.
Artifact Registry
gives you a scalable
build artifact management
with security and control.
You can focus on differentiating
your product offering
while enjoying the peace of mind
of knowing that your software
delivery process is backed
by Google Cloud Platform.
Artifact Registry
is currently in beta
with Docker support and
alpha support for Java
and node.js artifacts.
Now my teammate
Ray will show you
how Artifact Registry integrates
into the Java development
and release process.
RAY: Here we have a
simple Java microservice.
As you can see, we have created
different artifact repositories
in this GCP project to
manage the build artifacts
for this application--
one for container
images and another
for Java Maven artifacts.
These repositories are located
in specific GCP regions,
and they are configured with a
new repository native identity
access management provided
by Artifact Registry.
For example, permissions
are configured
to control who can
push or pull artifacts.
Artifact Registry
easily integrates
with your development
and release tool set.
If you are building a
common library in Java
to be used by all of your
business applications,
you can use Maven or Grado to
build and publish the packages
to Artifact Registry.
When building a container using
Docker or [INAUDIBLE] plug-in,
they can be configured to push
container images to Artifact
Registry as well.
Now, with all the artifacts
stored in Artifact Registry,
you can manage those
packages via the console
and [INAUDIBLE] command
line while applying
consistent permissions
across your repositories.
Artifact Registry
integrates with Cloud Build,
a third party CI/CD system.
Here we have set up a
Cloud Build pipeline that
builds the application,
publishes the Maven artifact
the artifact registry,
then builds and stores
the container image in
Artifact Registry as well.
From there, we can easily
deploy the container
into Google Cloud Runtimes such
as Kubernetes engine or Cloud
Run.
Artifact Registry is the
evolution of Container Registry
and gives you scalable
build artifact management
with security and control.
Visit our documentation
to learn how
to get started with
Docker, Maven, and NPM
in Artifact Registry.
[MUSIC PLAYING]